[Music]
what's interesting is high-conflict
personality seemed to we've really
boiled it down to four key
characteristics the first and maybe the
most stunning is a preoccupation with
blaming other people it's really it's
all your fault and you may have
experienced this and it's not at all my
fault that's zero my part of the problem
is zero and that's how high conflict
people talk and they'll say don't you
get it it's all your fault the second is
a lot of all-or-nothing thinking of
course it's all your fault
but my way or the highway solutions to
problems are there's all good people and
there's all bad people so they have this
kind of all-or-nothing perspective a
third is often but not always unmanaged
emotions and you may see that people
that just start yelling or just start
crying or just storm out of a room of
that kind of behavior we're seeing but
it's emotions that they're not managing
and the fourth is extremes of behavior
and one thing I talk about in the book
five types of people is this 90 percent
rule that ninety percent of people don't
do some of the things that high conflict
people do so if you see some shocking
behavior and then the person makes an
excuse for it that's often the tip of
the iceberg so it's preoccupation with
blaming others all-or-nothing thinking
unmanaged emotions and extreme behaviors
that seems to be the pattern for high
conflict personalities people that have
those we call AI conflict people but by
the way don't tell them that you think
that that will blow up in your face so
target of blame seems to be why these
folks can become so difficult if you're
the target of blame your life may be
ruined by one of these folks and that's
what people need to become aware of so
the target of blame each of these five
high conflict personalities tends to
zero
in generally on one person it could
change over time but they see that
person as the cause of all their
problems and so they want to control
that person or eliminate that person or
destroy or humiliate that person it's a
fixation on one person and all of their
life problems they emotionally focus on
that person so you don't want to be one
of those folks how to avoid being a
target of blame first of all if you see
warning signs of this behavior don't get
too close to such a person you may be a
friend but don't be the closest friend
you may be a co-worker but don't be the
closest co-worker because what seems to
happen is the people they get really
close to are the ones that are most at
risk of becoming their targets of blame
but it could be anybody they tend to
target intimate others and people in
authority so this could be boyfriends
girlfriends husbands wives parents
children co-workers neighbors they get
close to it also could be police could
be government agency or a government
official could be their boss could be
the company owner so they tend to focus
on intimate others and/or people in
authority now the way to avoid becoming
a target of blame not getting too close
to them but also not engaging in
conflict with them they often invite
conflict like they'll say outrageous
things and you may feel like you've got
to persuade them that they're wrong and
that's what I call a forget about it
just forget about it you're not gonna
change their mind if they're a difficult
person high-conflict person this is who
they are and you may not really even
exist for them so if you argue with them
they're not going to change so save
yourself the trouble but when people
challenge them is often when they turn
again
you and they see you and they're all or
nothing eyes as all bad and so you don't
want to have that kind of relationship
so if you're in a personal relationship
family relationship neighbor co-worker
etc you can manage relationships with
these folks but usually at an arm's
length and don't make it too
confrontational don't say they have a
high conflict personality don't argue
with them try to convince them don't try
to give them insight into themselves you
can just say oh well that's interesting
hey I've got to go now
something like that
[Music]